it is seven o'clock good to have your
company in dining Street this morning
and if you have a sense of deja vu
you're forgiven we have indeed been here
very very recently this morning little
more than seven weeks after she entered
number 10 as prime minister Liz truss
will walk out of that famous black door
behind me and Rishi sunak the PM in
Waiting will walk in and begin his
Premiership but will he survived until
the next election and just who will be
in his top team on today's program
former Justice Minister Victoria Atkins
has been put forward by team Rishi plus
the former environment secretary George
Eustis the former Tony party chair Rod
pickle still a den leader Ed David the
snps Ian Blackford and the shadow Chief
secretary through the treasury Pat
McFadden it is Tuesday the 25th of
October
Royal seal of approval Rishi sinak
prepares to meet the king to become the
new prime minister as he tells his party
unite or die
we now need stability and unity and I
will make it my utmost priority to bring
our party and our country together
Rishi reshuffle Jeremy Hunt expected to
stay as Chancellor although no final
decisions have been made who else could
be in line for a top cabinet job
first British Asian prime minister has
promised to get to work we'll discuss
what his leadership means for businesses
and schools struggling in the cost of
living crisis
prime minister and he's from a
privileged background but he now he
really needs to be in touch with his
public because we're all now looking to
him for results
one in one out the famous black door
will swing open for this trust this
morning to leave and tuition Center to
take over will this be the last prime
minister we have before an election
foreign
[Music]
will head to the Palace to meet King
Charles this morning where he'll be
invited to take over a country but one
beset by economic problems and to build
a cabinet from a deeply divided party he
will be the third prime minister in two
months do the maths and there'll be no
honeymoon period as he put it to his own
MPS just last night unite or die in a
moment we'll be joined by the former
Justice Minister Victoria Atkins has
been put forward by Rishi sunax team
plus we'll analyze who might be in line
for a top job in his cabinet with Jeremy
Hunt expected to remain as Chancellor
although no final decisions have been
made first of all let's take you through
the key events of the morning
at 9am I'm going prime minister Liz
truss will hold her final cabinet
meeting
quarter past 10 she's then expected to
make a short statement uh just a meter
away from where I'm standing outside
Downing Street she'll then travel to
Buckingham Palace to meet King Charles
after that the incoming prime minister
Rishi sunai will meet the king for his
audience at Buckingham Palace
you'll then travel back here to dining
Street where we expect him to make his
first speech as pm at around 11 35.
underneath
is Britain's youngest prime minister in
Modern Times And the first British Asian
in number 10 and today Rishi sunak
embarks on the twin challenges of
getting a grip on the economy and
uniting the bitterly divided
conservative party his message to his
MPS unite or Die the United Kingdom is a
great country
but there is no doubt we Face a profound
economic challenge
we now need stability and unity and I
will make it my utmost priority to bring
our party and our country together
on the economy Mr sunac is expected to
keep Jeremy Hunt as Chancellor and press
ahead with a plan to balance the
nation's books next week to unite his
MPS he's promised to include Talent from
across the party in his cabinet
so far so good I take great pride to
somebody who's been a member of the
conservative party for 35 years to say
the Tory party is back in business
Mr sunac became Chancellor in 2020 after
just five years in Parliament I worked
alongside Rishi in the treasury and I
saw how incredibly capable he is clearly
his grip of the economic issues how he
knows about the difficult decisions you
have to make in government between
public spending and public services and
taxes but many Tory activists like these
in Telford are Furious after being
denied a vote in the latest leadership
contest to foist this upon us without
having our say is not going to be
accepted by the the Party by the
Grassroots of the party we should have
had a democratic choice to elect our
leader to take the uh the uh the um
Mandate of 2019 the democratically
elected Mandate of 2019 forward
when he quit as Chancellor in July Mr
sunac wrote in his resignation letter it
may be his last ministerial job now
seven weeks after being rejected by
party members he's got the top job
John Craig Sky News
[Applause]
very pleased to see the former Justice
Minister and of course Rishi sunak
supporter Victoria Atkins joins us on
the program Miss act it's lovely to see
you and first things first can we get a
guarantee that we're not all going to be
back here in a few months time electing
another conservative leader and prime
minister
uh yes because uh having seen at the uh
the the reception that Rishi got
yesterday in the 1922 committee meeting
which is when we all get together as
members of parliament to uh debate the
great issues of the day the reception
which she got from across the party was
so uh inspiring to see and also so
comforting when you look at the range of
supporters across the party uh I think
we have a real chance here of you
lighting and the reason we want to unite
is because we realize the very very
grave issues facing the country and all
of us all of us whatever side of the
party we come from all of us want to
unite to work together to deliver for
our country and our constituents
with respect that's exactly what those
trust supporters told me seven weeks ago
today
they went too far too far too fast with
some of the measures that were announced
I wanted desperately wanted Liz to
succeed I'm a conservative I also want
to deliver for my constituents but I
think now that we've seen the reaction
of the markets and also there has been a
much greater debate as to the
precariousness of the world economy as
well as our own domestic economy economy
I I think and I'm convinced given the
reaction of members of parliament
yesterday and the unity that people
showed in uniting behind Rishi that we
will be able to move forward yeah we're
elected to deliver we want to do that
I mean presumably you're not talking
about people like Nadine Doris who says
a general election is now necessary
presumably you're not talking about
another end piece of Christopher chope
suggesting that uh that British sunak
supporters are hyenas uh certainly not
Mr Campbell Bannerman who Twisted a
picture last night of a snake on the
doorstep of number 10 with Rishi sunak's
face this doesn't strike me as a party
in the throes of unity
no I mean the last chap you mentioned
just then isn't a member of parliament
but um
yeah there are going to be uh look we
understand this is a it's been a very
very tough uh six weeks for us as a
party of course the country would be
saying well hang on a minute it's been a
very tough six weeks for us as well
which is why I think of course there
will be some bruised feelings among some
people but actually what we saw
yesterday was the overwhelming majority
of people coming together understanding
that we now have to focus on tackling
inflation we have to stabilize the
markets we have to try to help the bank
of England with the the difficult
decisions they have coming ahead of them
with interest rates and so on we have to
do everything we can to stabilize the
economy because if we can do that then
we can start to deliver the vision that
Rishi set out over the summer and that
we will all look forward to supporting
when there is a general election
sure there will however be people
watching this morning who do not simply
believe what you see because of the
destabilizing effect that the
conservatives have laterally had on on
the economy so so just in terms of
policy what is Rishi sunat going to do
to deal with that 40 odd billion pound
black hole as identified by pretty much
every Financial commentator I can find
well the first I'm very very conscious
that we need to regain people's trust
and so uh Rishi being the former
Chancellor that he is don't forget he uh
set up the furlough scheme had to deal
with the nightmare of the covert
pandemic within a month of becoming
Chancellor he managed it superbly and
said we knew all of that what is he
going to do about the black hole so in
terms of the black hole he will be
getting to work immediately with the
chancellor to address these issues
you'll you'll appreciate I'm not in the
room with them in those discussions
indeed but my goodness me we have a we
have someone in office who doesn't need
um lessons in how the you know how the
treasury works or whatever he will
absolutely get on with the job as soon
as he walks through that great big black
door but are there areas that should be
protected the health service for example
the three percent on on defense spending
well we um again Rishi has said that we
stood and and won an election in 2019 on
that Manifesto and he wants to stick to
that Manifesto and that seems to me uh
absolutely the right way forward and so
we're committed completely committed to
the NHS we know that this winter is
going to be a very difficult one for a
whole host of reasons not least the
backlogs that accumulated during the as
a result of the pandemic but also with
defense he's been very very clear that
for example we will continue to do
everything we need to do not just to
defend our country but also to help
Ukraine in particular which of course
that war that Dreadful war in Ukraine is
some of the reason for some of the
economic turmoil that the whole world is
seeing as a result of energy prices
escalating
but but we are going to be entering into
aren't we a period of austerity and it
will be a period of austerity in which
we have a prime minister who via
marriage is a billionaire so when Rishi
sunak stands up and says that there
isn't going to be any money to give
nurses to put their salaries up that
there isn't going to be money to pay for
school repairs or perhaps even some
covert compliance ventilation going on
in there it will be a billionaire saying
so how do you think the public will
react to that
so if I can just step back a little bit
from that because um as I say it
wouldn't be right for me to appear even
by inference to confirm
um what you're saying in that question I
think we've got to give Rishi and the
chancellor a bit of time and space to
work out the plans where you know Rishi
very much would once the a statement to
go ahead on 31st of October but
decisions will be made on that we've got
to take this step by step in terms of
how Rishi uh speaks the public
communicates with the public relates to
the public I think we saw it again in
the pandemic you know I'm not asking you
to imagine that he's good at this we
know he's good at this because we've
seen it as we were all huddled around
our televisions during lockdown and were
reassured by Rishi saying this is what
I'm going to do for you we're going to
put our arms around you and so I'm very
very confident that we will see more of
Rishi in that mode if you like
reassuring us stabilizing the markets
and it is notable by the way the
reaction of the markets over the last 24
hours I think think that again gives us
some small grounds for optimism and so I
think stabilizing the markets tackling
inflation because as Rishi said
throughout the summer that is the killer
with a lot of this you know if we've got
food inflation if we've got wage
inflation these are all difficult
difficult issues and Rishi has the
experience and the expertise to deal
with this
all of which makes whoever he puts
around the cabinet table with them
incredibly incredibly important
particularly of course the job in number
11. he's talked about building a
government of all the talents what do
you understand him to mean by that I
mean are we basically not going to about
to see a member of the ERG sitting
around the cabinet table
I think we have an enormous range of
talents across the party I'm not going
to name names if you'll forgive me
because I I don't want to make enemies
at seven o'clock in the morning but uh
fair enough now yeah but we have a huge
range of talent across the party and I
think one of the um sadnesses of uh
perhaps the last six weeks was that not
all of that Talent was really used and
really exploited if you like um by the
previous administration so I'm really
looking forward to some excellent
colleagues and we've got we've got a
huge range of experience in teaching
police and and so on across the board
I'd love to see some of our expertise
and experience come into our government
so that we're shaping policies and
delivering policies that really make a
difference for our country
meet the case then if you can for the
country not being given a vote on what
is you know the the third prime minister
we've had in you know a handful of
months why is no not the right time I
mean you've gone through the decision
breaking process now twice internally
within the conservative party by your
own admission you got it wrong the first
time you know you're keeping your
fingers crossed on this one I mean why
not a little more than that you know
forgive me a little bit on that I'm very
confident about uh this Administration
uh in terms of demand I think there are
two actually two primary reasons first
of all it's completely practical which
is my goodness me we have got a lot to
deal with at the moment we have to
stabilize the markets we have to
stabilize the economy we have to ensure
for example that the energy price
guarantee that Liz introduced that's a
phenomenal package that would make sense
that would make sense that would make
sense if the first thing I'd say to his
MPS was not unite or die I mean this is
all about the existential crisis the
conservative party is facing it's
nothing to do with country
no no and the second reason if I may for
um uh the the big question about an
election and forgive me this is a bit of
sort of constitutional uh law in the in
the middle of the the beginning of the
morning for people who've just woken up
but uh we do we elect we elect a party
you know it's a conservative Manifesto
in 2019 uh we don't have a presidential
system and I am responsible and uh I am
representative of my constituents but
I'm also accountable to them so we stood
on that Manifesto we deliver it and of
course in Parliament it is the less
trust did not deliver the 2019 Manifesto
who can command a majority and and His
Majesty the king will invite uh that
person to deliver a government look I
think I mean again I think Liz would
accept that she stepped away from the
2019 Manifesto there were particular
issues that's my point why should we no
believe you that sunai will not I mean
the last prime minister that was in post
for seven weeks said he's over the same
thing you know Cameron give us my plan
put it to the country but so what's the
difference I mean you've already shown
that the conservative party cannot be
trusted to the 2019 Manifesto commitment
with the last World current prime
minister because because Rishi said we
will stick to the 2019 Manifesto it's as
simple as that so yeah we will continue
to see the focus on leveling up we'll
continue to see the focus on the NHS on
on security my own personal area of sort
of expertise and interest if you will is
supporting violence or attacking
violence against women girls supporting
victims of domestic abuse and so on we
want to continue all of these pieces of
work as we deal with this very very
difficult issue of our domestic economy
in the context of the international
problems that other countries are facing
as well so look I appreciate that it's
been a pretty you know it's been a
brutal six weeks in politics for lots of
people it's been a very very fast pace
but we now behind Rishi will have a
stability and confidence and reassurance
that I hope will begin to make a real
difference to people's lives over the
coming weeks and months
I I know I've got to let you go but I
can't let let you go without this cheeky
little question at the end have you got
a job
[Laughter]
yeah indeed okay Victoria Atkins lovely
to have you on the program Take Care
thank you so much take care
joining us here in Downey Street all
morning our political correspondent
Tamara Cohen Tamara and of course
Victoria Atkins put forward by cchq this
morning she is the representative of
Rishi sunak what did we make of what we
had well is it going to be Third Time
Lucky essentially for the conservatives
we're here seven weeks to the day since
Liz trust walked into another drizzly
day in Downey Street Boris Johnson
having gone that morning and now we're
going to be doing it all again this
morning with Rishi sunak who lost the
contest despite winning the support of
most of his colleagues including
Victoria Atkins who was one of those
cast out into the cold by Liz truss for
not supporting her and she was
suggesting there that Rishi that would
not just talk about a government of all
the talents which all governments do but
actually do it actually bring in people
who didn't agree with him who didn't
necessarily support him in order for the
party to what he said to his colleagues
yesterday was unite or die they can all
see the polls they can all see where
they are and he says we have to now
crack on with her she put it tackling
inflation and the rising cost of living
and The crucial first decisions will be
today on who he puts in his top team
shall we play a little bit of early
morning cabinet Bingo and where should
we start uh well how about with the post
of Chancellor at the moment of course
Jeremy Hunt it would be difficult for
him to move wouldn't it the strong
expectation is that Jeremy Hunt stays
and one of the reasons for that is
obviously he has the Market's confidence
but he's supposed to deliver that
statement the fiscal statement on how to
balance the book next Monday the 31st
it'd be difficult for someone else to
get up to speed on that so that's our
strong expectation we also think that he
might bring back some of those figures
who are not in cabinet at the moment the
likes of Sajid Javid of course former
Health secretary and former lots of
other things as well in a key post kemi
badanok was a supporter of this trust in
the end having run herself big figure on
the right of the party
trade there's suggestions that she
doesn't like trade and wants a more
forward-facing position
um
she of course was in the running until
the last few minutes yesterday refused
to make a deal with uh Rishi sooner
actually insisted that she was going to
get to the 100 MPS having not made a
deal she is now we understand pressing
to be foreign secretary will he will he
give her that big reward which involves
getting rid of James cleverley though
doesn't it of course and you'd think
even though James cleverly supported
Boris Johnson in this round of the
contest he's seen as a safe Pair of
Hands at the foreign office so will
penny more than he offered something
else and will she take it or will she
stay outside the tent James cleverley
foreign secretary he may well stay in a
gesture of reaching out to other Boris
Johnson supporters Grant shaft being
home secretary for under five minutes
about a matter of days he is a supporter
of Richie sunac but there are
suggestions that some of which is unex
other supporters even someone like
Dominic Robb who has really done some
heavy lifting in the media for Rishi
sunak he might be rewarded with that job
so we'll be a move there and he he will
it looks like bringing some of the right
Wingers in the party like Zoella bravman
recently obligated from the home office
presumably presumably she was offered
something for her support well she wrote
a very effusive article in this
Telegraph by Richie sunac which
suggested that so she will be offered we
assume something difficult to bring her
back to the home office after she
resigned over a security breach so
perhaps a different job justice as she
is a lawyer Mel stride big supporter
British unac ran his leadership campaign
is likely to get something and Oliver
dowdon another figure from the last
cabinet also a big Rishi supporter we
expect he may get a role and the former
deputy prime minister Dominic Robb
tipped for a return as well as Ben
Wallace will he be this is interesting
question for me because yeah he
supported ish Boris has been very firm
on the three percent
um GDP spending on on defense well up
until relatively well that's interesting
he was putting about the idea that he
would resign if there wasn't an increase
in defense spending to three percent and
that that's why he supported most trust
because she was promising that but I was
hearing over the last few days sources
close to Ben Wallace saying that is not
exactly what he said so would he stay in
defense with a smaller settlement or
would he in that situation say no I'm
going to go and Michael Gove could it be
the ultimate combat for Michael Gove
there are some plenty of difficult jobs
to do in government and I'm sure he
would happily take on anything I I'm
absolutely certain that you're right
Tamara thank you very much indeed uh so
let's have a quick look shall we at how
some of the papers are covering the
wider reaction to rishi's soon after
coming leader you can put that down now
the rain's off in the trains at the
headline sunac tells the Tories unite or
die
and while the matter asks who voted for
you stating that Rishi sunak takes Parma
without winning a single vote as people
across the country called for a general
election
the telegraph well it says that Rishi
sunak's crowning moment was like The X
Factor uh except nobody actually worked
voted for the winner interesting take by
Tim Stanley
um according to the mail however the new
prime minister Herald's a new dawn for
Britain
alternative taking the star it pictures
the third prime minister this year as
October's calendar boy and asks will he
last until the end of the month
I'll find out in a few days won't we
still to come on the program at 20 past
roughly I'll be speaking to the former
chairman of the conservative party Lord
pickles
I will also be speaking to a head
teacher about the possible impact of
spending cuts on schools budgets
and we'll also be getting reaction from
the shadow Chief secretary to the
treasury Pat McFadden it's where she
soon executes the keys to number 10.
how about some other news now and Russia
says it will take its claims that cave
is pertaining to use a radioactive dirty
bomb to the U.N security Council later
today now the West fears the Russian
claims could be the pretext for a
further escalation of the war our Europe
correspondent Adam Parsons asked
Ukraine's top security official whether
he thinks Russia will use a dirty blonde
bomb I'm trying to blame it on Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
speak to Andrew who joins us now out
from Keith and very good morning I mean
at this distance from Ukraine people are
genuinely concerned when the Russians
start talking about dirty bombs I can
only imagine at what it's like where you
are
yeah I think there is uh here in Ukraine
a sort of certain stoicism they've heard
so much and so many threats and seen so
much violence in their country over the
past eight months or so that this is
just another one to add to the list but
I I think the response that you have
seen not just from uh Alexi danielov and
from uh Vladimir zielinski to these
claims of preparing a dirty bomb but
also from officials in UK and Washington
Paris and and Beyond probably speaks
volumes I mean the simple fact is that
nobody no Diplomat thinks that there is
any chance that Ukraine is going to a
possess a dirty bomb and B use it on its
own territory with the expectation that
somehow Russia would get the Bain from I
mean there are so many dots there it
it's almost sort of risible I mean one
we should say when we talk about a dirty
bomb we're talking about a high
explosive bomb with radioactive material
around it it's not the same as a nuclear
bomb although of course that threat
still lingers in the air and like we
spoke to Mr danalov I also asked him
about that and his response was pretty
much along the lines of whatever Russia
does we will cope with it Russia of
course still maintains that Ukraine uh
recurring is preparing some sort of
dirty device I don't think that's
reality I think this is about PR and
Maneuvers and some kind of diplomatic
strategy that the Russians are preparing
there are those who think it could be
laying the ground towards a proposal of
a ceasefire here in Kiev I don't think
they would take it
Adam many thanks
now it's claimed that Rising builds are
pushing more households onto prepayment
gas and electricity meters the
comparison website uswitch says that 60
000 new meters were installed in Britain
in the six months to March some
suppliers put customers on prepayment
meters if they struggle to keep up with
their bills
the United States has charged two
suspected Chinese spies with attempting
to obstruct a criminal investigation
into the Chinese Tech Giant Huawei the
two men are accused of paying tens of
thousands of dollars in cash and jewelry
to bribe the U.S law enforcement
official the person they tried to
recruit was in fact a double agent
working for the FBI
Harvey Weinstein is back in court and
further charges of rape and sexual
assaults the disgrace film producer is
facing 11 charges of rape and sexual
assault between 2004 and 2015.
sad Wellness the actor Leslie Jordan has
died in a car crash at the age of 67.
the Will and Grace star was known for as
some distinctive Southern American
accent his viral videos made during
lockdown and of course his characters
distinctive way of entering a room
well
[Applause]
no speaking of Diwali celebration last
night the U.S President Joe Biden called
Rishi sunak's appointment as the UK's
first British Asian prime minister
pretty astounding
just today we've got news for Russia
machines
Sanuk is now the prime minister
as my brother would say go figure
and the conservative party
expected to become the Prime Minister I
think tomorrow when he goes to see the
king
pretty astounding
a groundbreaking Milestone and it
matters it matters
will of course become the third prime
minister this year and many people
aren't demanding a general election as
Tom Parmenter found out in
leicestershire others just want him to
get on with the job
foreign they want everything just right
here
because it's tough selling electrical
Goods to a cash-strapped public
good afternoon holes Alison runs the
accounts here you don't see so many
people about nobody there spend
nobody dare spend anything
and that's all down to the political
situation oh definitely
yeah they just need to sort it all out
struggling to get hold of stock with
some things yeah it's it's difficult
Chris's Grandad started this business in
the 1930s alongside his electricals
they're trying out a toy shop anything
to change their fortunes as the Prime
Minister changes again it affects
everybody in the UK it does everybody
and that's what they need to stop and
think about we must be the laughing
stock of the political world
we watched in the shop as it was all
confirmed as long as he gets on and
gets on with the job now and tries to
sort things out that's really what
matters
and whichever way your corner of the
country votes this cuts through every
community
you hear that frustration in cities
towns Villages even hamlets here in
rural middle England people have been
embarrassed by the circus in Westminster
and quite often they've suffered because
of it
all right
the day when the country found out it
would have its first British Asian prime
minister coincided with this
when he succeeded today even even to the
last moment I was thinking oh no no he's
not going to make it he's not going to
make it but then many did it just blew
me out
Leicester always hosts one of the
biggest Diwali parties outside of India
it drew Rita here from Essex as people
out there that are really really
struggling and obviously he's had a bit
of a privileged lifestyle I think he
needs to kind of be in touch yeah he's
the first Asian prime minister and he's
from a privileged background but he now
he really needs to be in touch with his
public because we're all now looking to
him for results
and that's the point the people now
living in sunax Britain won't accept
just more of the same
Tom Farmington Sky News leicestershire
well let's put some of the points in
Tom's report to the former conservative
party chairman of course former
communities and local government
secretary uh Eric pickles now of course
Lord pickles love to see you this
morning um will very very soon be off to
see at the king um was this the result
you were after
in the summer so I'm I'm quite pleased
to see him uh there no disrespect of
course to Liz but I think um he had a
very good grasp of what we need to do
and I wish him well
what is the first task that a new prime
minister particularly one who is not
entering Downing Street after a general
election what is the first task that
they have to do is it to reach out to
the public or is it to steady the
internal struggles that the party's been
going through
I don't think it's a binary choice I
think there are a number of things that
I need to do I mean obviously he
recognizes that he needs to ensure that
the conservative party uh comes together
it needs to ensure that there's going to
be a balanced uh cabinet and that people
are appointed on on marriage rather than
just rewarding mates there's got the
economics you've got to be very clear in
terms of his fiscal economic policy and
he's got to put across a very clear
set of policies I've not been entirely
sure what the conservative party stood
for for a number of months and I think
that needs to Big up across very clearly
to the public and I think above all
um to ensure that Downing Street
works for the last uh three prime
ministers it's been largely
dysfunctional I think it's great and
almost been an impediment to good
government
but and you're going to form a role as
Chairman's party chairman I mean you
know a thing or two about party
discipline and and how to keep it and it
strikes me the moment there are any
number of people who are at least at the
very at the very least slightly
inaudible I mean the party membership as
you saw in Tom's report there a large
chunk of them will be feeling
marginalized by the fact that they
didn't get to have a have a say in all
of this
I kind of understand that but you know
you know this isn't a game this isn't
student politics it's about forming a
government and uh we we need a
government very quickly and I think it
might have been a self-indulgent even to
waste a week to have a a a a competition
that would have been largely settled by
uh the number of parliaments I
understand that's a fairly brutal thing
to say but I do think it's uh important
that we get on uh get on with the job
but you see I think part of the problem
is that there's been too many Chief
whips and sovereign
so what they've got to do is make people
want to go through the lobbies with them
what they've got to do with the general
party is to offer some leadership not by
that not by threats or by pushing the
people through into lobbies but by
actually getting some enthusiasm uh
together in terms of of how we want to
uh help the British public and put some
policies through for goodness sake
but what do you do to quell the kind of
the growing calls for the general
election they're obviously most
prominent from the opposition benches
but you do also have people like Nadine
dollar suggesting that that actually
given what has happened over the past
three four months you know putting it
putting it into the country might not be
a bad idea
well suppose I understand the British
constitution when I am claiming I do
completely is if you can command a
maturity and answer Commons uh you can
form a government and it's as simple as
that I mean I understand a number of
colleagues of uh of our former
colleagues have said that well if they
want to seek the children confidence I
would enthusiastic go out and countless
for them if they solve the election
you yourself have of course been very
keenly involved in a number of
conservative elections I'm just
wondering if you were kind of advising
the sunac team at the moment we are of
course the middle of a cost of living
crisis everyone has less money in their
pockets these days there are going to
have to be some very very big difficult
decisions made on public spending and
they're all going to be being announced
by a guy who through manage admittedly
is a billionaire I mean how do you how
do you counteract the Optics of a
situation in which a man richer than
creases is telling nurses that they
can't have an extra 10 or a week
I mean I'm sure he's sort of aware of
that but I don't think we should look
down our noses at somebody just because
they you know they've got a moment too I
um
well a large cup of tea that would uh
make you happy
um but what you've got is it is about I
think he's capable of walking other
people's shoes I think he does have
empathy and and time will tell
um but I think he's a very competent guy
uh and um I wish him well
I suppose then that the final question
should be I mean if it doesn't go well
if he doesn't study the [ __ ] if he
doesn't you know deal with the economy
in a way in which the Market's like I
mean Rishi sunak has a shelf life
doesn't he
we all every politician has a shelf life
I think people need to understand no
matter how important you are you're
essentially in politics you've got a
summer lease you're there for a while
and and then you're gone uh but I think
it's more a stake here than the fate of
uh of Rishi sunak it's the effect of the
nation and the in a really difficult
time you know you you have a brilliant
report there about what's going on uh in
the Ukraine there's instability in the
world uh we've got to offer the
conservative party and Mr Cena has got
to offer leadership right across this
and to try and bring us through these
difficult problems
Eric pickles Lord pickles I should say
great to have you on the program thanks
for being with us thank you
now eagle-eyed viewers may have already
seen Larry the cat has been out this
morning on the hunt
for the next cabinet appointment uh
we'll be going through who might be in
line for those in much more detail with
you again in the next uh with Tamara and
of course Liz truss will be holding our
final cabinet here at 9am so we'll be
hoping that some of them might want to
talk to us as they're arriving
I think we'll get more chance with the
cat frankly uh head teachers you know a
warning that 9 out of 10 schools will be
running out of money by the next
academic year if there isn't more
funding but as soon as next week the new
government is expected by many to bring
in spending cuts across all departments
uh joining us now Simon Kidwell vice
president of the National Association of
head teachers and indeed a head teacher
himself at Simon great to have you on
the program just tell us about the
situation that that you are facing at
the moment and indeed those of your
members
So currently we've um we're actually
facing a two billion pound shortfall by
the end of this Parliament so for my own
individual school that means we're
approximately 80 000 pounds down from
what we set our budget to which relates
to um two teachers or for teaching
assistants so we're facing um
significant staff reductions
um unless we can actually get the two
billion pound that was promised in the
2019 Manifesto
so why are these pressures
why are these pressures emerging at this
point is this all related to cost of
living imagine your energy bills are
through the roof it's partly cost of
living but it's also the we had an
unfunded pay rise so um the pay Rises
which have been earmarked for teachers
and teaching assistants aren't funded at
all so that's causing additional
pressure as well as cost of living uh
pressures like energy and food bills
so when will you have to make a decision
on whether or not to call staff
well this year we've got um a capital
um budget where we were looking to
refurbish a toilet Block in schools we
are putting that on hold at the moment
so we may be able to get through this
financial year but the following
Financial year is where we were looking
at stat reductions and if you look at
that across the whole country we're
looking at a reduction of 38 000
teachers if we don't get the 2 billion
pound which was promised in a 2019
Manifesto
I mean the the government of course it
is in a state of flux at the moment but
the government would say that it is
facing a crisis at the moment and that
it is already pumping money into
education I mean a DFE spokesman said
this we understand that schools are
facing cost pressures due to
international events driving up Energy
prices she added that as well as the
energy relief scheme schools would
receive 53.8 billion in core funding
which includes they say a cash increase
of of 4 billion I mean it's not enough
for you is it
you know those figures are accurate but
what we didn't have when we um had those
funding agreements at the start of this
problem we didn't know the cost of
living crisis was going to happen so we
heard from Eric pickles previously about
global instability but I would say to
the Prime Minister we really need to
make sure that we don't put instability
into our schools our schools are really
on a life Edge and so many organizations
are speaking out we've got um CEOs of
large Academy trust we've got the people
that signed the letter that went to the
conservative MPS we really don't want to
be putting this level of instability
into our schools because it means our
schools won't look like they have done
over the last 10 years
I mean 50 as it says on the screen there
50 of head teachers seeing their school
will be in deficit this year so so let's
be absolutely direct about this Rishi
sunak is the new prime minister well
we'll be shortly what do you need to see
from him and Jeremy Hunt
but we need to see that recommitment we
they talked about unity in unifying the
party around 2019 Manifesto promises so
if they are going to unify the party we
know that local MPS that schools are
very dear to their hearts and they need
to find that money and they need to see
schools as a investment in the future
um the two billion pound we're looking
for is about six miles of hs2 Railway so
really do need to start looking at stop
looking at stores as a burden on the
public person start saying it's an
investment for the future if we put
money into children and their futures
um well Simon We wish you well with
those efforts Simon Cadwell many thanks
for being with us
but pressure is also building on the
government to increase the number of
free School meals to help the Buddhist
families struggling with the rising cost
of living I'm joined Now by Marine big a
former Ted a former teacher who
currently Volunteers in a school in
London Maureen lovely to talk to you
just tell us about what what you see on
a daily basis in your school
um so I actually I come from a family of
teachers
um my brother's a teacher my sister's a
teacher my friends my sister-in-law
everybody
um so it's not just about what I've seen
but it's also about stories that I'm
hearing from across
um the country actually
um I recently tweeted about one
particular incident of a student in one
of the schools that I volunteer in
um and one of our students nearly passed
out from hunger and immediately the
teacher I was with took out two apples
and gave her two apples and she took one
of them and she put them she put it into
her bag for her sibling to have when she
goes home that day there are kids who I
mean people are sharing their stories on
social media with me now and there are
kids who are collecting sachets of
tomato ketched up hoping to make tomato
soup at home there are kids who are
wrapping up leftovers in tissues
secretly to take home for dinner there
are kids who are pretending to eat out
of empty lunch boxes because they're not
only hungry but they're embarrassed and
ashamed and this isn't you know it's not
about one isolated incident this is
happening across the country I started
teaching
in
2011. so my teaching career correlated
with a decade of austerity and I was
teaching in a particularly disadvantaged
Borough in London and it was very normal
for us to use our own money to buy food
for our students but what's becoming
really evident now is that this is a
story which is not just
um happening in some of our deprived
areas this is happening across the
country there are 800
000 students I think children who are
suffering from food insecurity in child
poverty
um skipping meals and they're not
entitled to free School meals this is
now a widespread issue just just on that
just on that topic and Marine you think
that a lot of this story resonates with
me because again I'm from a family of
teachers both of my parents were
teachers they had pastoral
responsibility and I remember them
talking about doing exactly what what
you were doing but why are so many kids
just explain this for our viewers why
are so many kids not qualifying for free
School meals when clearly they are in
need of them
saying not just the poor asleep in the
country is affecting I mean it's going
through all layers of society with
energy bills increasing rent prices and
everything going up families are
struggling so it's not just the poorest
people in society now who are struggling
to keep up with the demand that that
people's income is not covering basic
key living costs parents are having to
make decisions on whether they're going
to have Heating in their house where
they're going to keep a roof over their
child's head or whether they're going to
feed them and that genuinely is the
reality and actually like I say when I
put this out one of the stories out on
social media I was so taken aback not
just by how widespread the problem is
but also at the ignorance that surrounds
it a lot of people say you know well
some money to teach these parents to
budget but you can't budget with money
that you don't have
certainly just just briefly then because
we're just about to run out of time what
then does Rishi soon like on day one of
his spelling number 10. what does he
need to do to deal with you know
starving kids in schools I can't even
believe I'm saying this in the 21st
century
yeah we are what the sex
country in the world and our children
are hungry
um what I'd say to Rishi sunak is that
between all of these leadership battles
and political chaos the needs of
children and schools and education and
teachers has been ignored and that
should be the priority of any civilized
country we need to invest in education
we need to invest in young people or
we're going to face the consequences of
that for years to come so I hope Rishi
sunak uses some of his 730 million pound
net worth to combat child poverty and
feed Starving Children across the
country
Maureen great to talk to you thanks so
much for your uh for your input
no did our new figures out this morning
on the cost of living and the price
increase in everyday Goods Matthew
Thompson is at a preschool club for us
in North London Matthew tell us what are
we finding out
some pretty striking statistics from the
ons today Neil showing that the lowest
cost items in supermarkets have risen
considerably more in the last year in
price than the headline inflation rate
so the lowest cost items in supermarkets
have risen 17 as against of course
headline inflation of 10 but we also
know that that food and drink inflation
is a little bit higher than that 15 but
what it shows quite clearly is that
lower cost items which of course tend to
be bought by lower paid people rise
quicker and in price than than others
and it shows it adds to a number of uh
comments and research in the last year
or so done by people like Jack Monroe
who I'm sure you'll be familiar with who
have pointed out that quite often when
inflation is rampant it is the people on
lowest incomes who are hit harder by it
and if you look at just some of the
individual items that the ons looked at
they're really quite striking so
vegetable oil for example Rose 65
percent in price in the last year
pasta Rose by 60 T Rose by 46 and now
clearly we should be we should be clear
about it large percentage increases of
low-cost items are still low cost but
they do compare extraordinarily those
figures 65 46 as I say to headline
inflation of 10 and food and drink
inflation of 15. so again what we know
is that inflation tends to hit those who
are already finding it hard to cope with
energy bills heating bills whatever else
it may be they buy lower cost items in
the shops and the data shows those lower
cost items rise quicker in price
Matthew thanks very much indeed I'll
just get my producer to move his big kid
out of the way there and let's have a
quick look at rishi's entry and like my
producer's head it's a big one he needs
to make an immediate decision over the
medium-term fiscal plan details of which
are due to be released on the 31st of
October following on from September's
disastrous mini budget the new PM will
have to decide if that date is still
feasible he'll also face pressure to
address the energy crisis as winter fast
approaches similarly you'll have to
tackle the cost of living crisis
and work out how to proceed with the
Northern Ireland protocol and also
maintain the UK support for Ukraine
let's bring in tomato corn at this point
and someone we've not really been
talking about this morning but we should
probably reflect on them let's try I
mean we saw a glimpse of it when she
announced her resignation I imagine we
might see it again today but this will
have affected her master
Lee Liz truss is sharing her final
cabinet meeting today not quite sure
what the point of it is but she will be
saying farewell to those around the top
table many of whom will be leaving their
positions at the top table today she
gave an 89 second resignation speech
last week not really reflecting on where
she went wrong she said I can't deliver
the Mandate I was elected to deliver by
conservative people expecting that this
morning are you what would I'm
fascinated by what she will say today
will she say any more about how she got
it wrong will she talk about regrets she
seems to be somebody who is not keen to
show much emotion to show much of what
is inside but you know this is seven
weeks as prime minister our shortest
live prime minister ever this is
obviously a personal tragedy for her and
many would say the country who are
seeing the effects of the mini budget in
their day-to-day lives but she is not
widely expected to be given a cabinet
job who knows if she actually wants one
but what happens to her as one of our
shortest lived former prime minister
what she goes on to do will she write
her memoirs will she make any big
interventions on any subject her
economic policy is lies in tatters and
that is you know as a final day of Liz
truss's Premiership it will be
fascinating I think to see what she has
to say about it
um timona thank you very much indeed
well let's reflect on what we've just
heard from tomorrow at 30 p.m this year
a fifth in six years does the
Constitution need a shake up on his
Parliament simply not measuring up uh
let's speak to you political historian
Sir Anthony Selden Sir Anthony lovely to
see you again and first and foremost
what do you make of the fact that Rishi
sunak is soon to be the next prime
minister
yeah well I I didn't get job it's a good
uh for the market it's good for the
country there for that we have a a
proven prime minister who is known to be
uh sensible uh understands economics and
finance but also understands uh uh the
politics of it all
um which his predecessor his two
predecessors didn't uh Boris Johnson
didn't understand public finances always
wanted to spend more uh mistrust myself
had some very good ideas but had no
sense of timing enriching soon act as we
can see from the markets there's
somebody in who they and business have
confidence and that's above all what we
need from the prime minister
as we've just heard on your program are
very perilous uh time in some ways the
worst inheritance since 1945 we tend to
exaggerate and we always say that an
incoming prime minister has the worst
inheritance since uh William the
Conqueror but uh it really is pretty
bleak on all fronts at the moment and
that's why it makes it so unusual and so
um difficult for the prime minister so
Financial competence is the absolute uh
basic requirement and he's got it
auntie I just have to check that's not
you tinkling the ivories whilst talking
to Sky and users I mean it's certainly
an appropriate soundtrack for what's
going on at the moment no can you can
you still hear me Sir Anthony
over the piano music yes
[Music]
obliging pianist uh is is completely
ivory
uh providing
backdrop uh to this most dramatic moment
in history who doesn't want a bit Honky
Tonk whilst we're talking big political
matter so tell us exactly what happens
today Liz truss would expect him to
leave here around about quarter past ten
after speaking so what actually happens
behind those closed doors at the palace
well uh the civil servants uh already
will have a whole series of briefs
greeted by the cabinet secretary Simon
case is also head of the Civil Service
and he will offer advice uh to uh the
Prime Minister about the need for
probity ethical uh Behavior which
um is all important considering what's
happened about the uh they'll have an
intelligence briefing immediately about
imminent threats to the country he'll
have to sign the letters of uh write the
letters of last resource about in the
event of a nuclear strike uh what would
we recommend the submarine commanders
with the nuclear weapons to do that
that's normally been something of of uh
which seemed like a far distance away
but now because of Vladimir Putin the
risk of nuclear war becomes higher and
he will start addressing himself uh and
after a long period in which the civil
service has been marginalized in Downing
Street uh the Civil Service which has
feared every single successful prime
minister in our history to sensible
conclusions by giving them the options
for them to decide they will be already
have a whole series of briefs and
presentations for Mr sunac at
of course
um although he's been Chancellor he's
never been prime minister and nothing
anywhere in government prepares you for
the massive uh step up it's like moving
from the second floor of a building up
to the 25th floor uh everything looks
very very different and you need a a
capacious mind and a great deal of calm
which I think uh Mr sunac certainly has
do you think he's up to it then
nobody
it's so unlike any other job in
government Home Secretary foreign
secretary Chancellor the exchequer even
leader of the opposition which he hasn't
been uh but the indications are that
he's got skills in the very area that is
most going to be in demand and let's
face it there's very little the
conservatives can do in the two years if
it is two years for the next general
election just calm competence are
getting uh the ship of state and the
economy back on of course our competence
in the Health Service uh wisdom with
strength abroad rebuilding relationships
with the EU sorting out uh Wars in
Ireland if the incoming prime minister
and that team can do that uh that will
be a very great uh tick for them but
imagining they're going to come in with
a big New Philosophy is Pie in the Sky
there's no time there's no opportunity
for new directions now
Serenity I think we can both agree that
one piece of legislation that needs to
be passed immediately is to Outlaw
pianos and train stations uh Sir Anthony
sells and thank you very much
[Music]
stick with us here on Sky News we will
of course be here in dining streets
throughout the day in terms of what
we're about to see well let's trusts
will be leaving number 10 Rishi sunak
will be arriving see you next time
[Music]